are you a good neighbor i would i would
i'd be a terrible terrible neighbor
howard
that's what i figured terrible neighbor
you're a terrible neighbor
in that um do you have a lot of parties
do you have a lot of people hanging out
it's going to be rough here because in
in the garage is an entire like
motorcycle shop so there's
and they're building this there's
they're building a motorcycle in there
right now and they
test this thing like like
you know when like your friends come
back from the bar and like they want to
like show off whatever they've done or
whatever like that happens
once a night here and it's always at
like 2 30 in the morning and you just
you're like
[Music]
and you hear them like yeah one of my
ears my nose terence j
two days ago he was having a party and i
popped over the fence i do we have like
what's that one show
like what defense guy home improvement
home improvement yo that one
that we have that relationship like i
literally will just be like
i'll like be like oh hey what's going on
today and there will be like you know
kanye west in the back
backyard one day or you know so and so
so
yes two days ago i like popped over it
was like kevin durant
but i like this whole dynamic of where
you live the one neighbor is fun
and then the other neighborhood very fun
[ __ ] hates you because you're noisy
and you've got
noise park in front of his bushes like
they're like very well done bushes
they're they're really nice bushes but
it's like you got the big side of the
sidewalk man like come on like do they
ever call the police on you
i don't think he ever has did you ever
go over and try to have a sit down with
him and say look maybe certainly
i sent a a dom period bottle over on a
skateboard one time
oh you did and i'm sure he loved that
who sent these parties
i might come out there and hang with you
you haven't met your match for me man
when you see me party you're not even
gonna [ __ ] believe it
oh yeah i hope you have some food yeah
and you better have fun
and make sure that party starts at five
o'clock so i can be out by eight
that's my scene